this morning we're launching a new
summer series I love the name it's
called American wonders from majestic
natural landscapes to spectacular
creations every week we're going to take
you to places that make America well
wonderful set in a hillside in the
central California city of Paso Robles
is a field of light it's 15 acres filled
with tiny little light bulbs of vibrant
colors this art installation comes alive
for visitors only when it's dark outside
that's cold Jamie yuccas is there with
what makes a spot so beautiful Jamie I
thought it was cool looking at it on the
screen so how would you describe what
you're looking at
I don't know Gael beautiful dazzling
immersive whatever you want to call it
this outdoor art installation known as
the field of light has a sneaky little
goal of trying to get people to connect
with nature using all this eye candy and
from what we saw a couple of weeks ago
seems to be working
nature's beauty is highlighted with a
little help from technology more than
58,000 solar-powered spheres shimmer and
shine winding through the fields in Paso
Robles a my feeling is that this is
magic well the landscape is Magic this
mesmerizing installation is the work of
British artist Bruce Monroe all I would
say to everybody is keep looking at
nature and all the answers are there for
us to discover the discovery begins in
the early evening as visitors gather for
food and wine and a stroll through the
field first in daylight
then as the Sun Goes Down the experience
changes it's what the world needs right
now you see all the beautiful light and
potential and possibility the idea came
to light a world away in uluru Australia
when Munro visited back in 1992 near
this ancient sandstone considered sacred
to the indigenous peoples Munro
experienced a kind of revelation I felt
that there was this sort of energy
coming out of the floor of the desert
that's when I realized that how you feel
in expressing
how you feel is really a very important
part of art after the death of his
father and turning 40 Munro felt the
need to create something more so he
bought a home in England with a field
behind it and refinanced it in order to
build his first field of light I assume
that was kind of a difficult discussion
with your wife there wasn't really a
discussion at the time and I promise you
I've never done this thing before I all
since my wife wasn't best pleased when
she saw that the field sort of sporting
these flowers of light and she looked
into the heavens and thought oh my god
what's he done so I I did say I'm sorry
and she's forgiven me you're still
married with still mine he went back to
Uluru to create the first large-scale
field of light which put him on the map
as an artist over the last 15 years he's
created whimsical scenes including a
blue moon a sparkling sea of CDs even
lollipops of light here at since Oreo in
central California imaginations are
running wild lights just pop up so well
together I kind of saw emotions emotions
yeah like what
blue sad orange is frustrated red is
angry pink is in love we're children the
field of light a massive collection of
fiber-optic cables is meant to enhance
the natural surroundings it's art that
touches the soul might solve a few
problems in the world if we did a bit
more of this and more of this is what
Monroe is ready to do lighten up the
world with a memorable glow the field is
located halfway between Los Angeles and
San Francisco so if you want to get here
it's about a three and a half to four
hour drive it's open Wednesdays through
Sundays through January the fifth and it
didn't stop anybody that distance from
coming here we had visitors the night we
were here from Minnesota and London so
Vlad Gael Tony who can I get to jump in
the car with me and come on up here next
time we want to come
by pink I think Jamie has it right or
Jack Jack's I think is Lulu is sad
orange is frustrated red is angry david
says pink is in love and then all the
kids laugh because love seems it's
beautiful what he's done there love it